[Música]
esse é o arco do triunfo
talvez alguns de vocês até o conheço
pessoalmente
outros como eu têm que se contentar em
conhecê lo pelo street view
ele foi construído como uma forma de se
homenagear as vitórias militares do
exército de napoleão bonaparte e está
localizado em uma das mais famosas além
de dois do mundo
a champs elysées
esse também é o eco do triunfo só que
agora ele é visto sob uma outra
perspectiva
ele é visto do alto observem como pela
imagem aérea é possível compreender
melhor como o arco sintero com sua
paisagem como todas as ruas convergem de
forma que as pessoas que trafegam por
essa região tem aqui notá lo como é bem
arborizado as suas ruas ao entorno e
toda a simetria da arquitetura dessa
região da capital francesa
todas essas análises só foram possíveis
porque a imagem aérea no permitiu
informações que dificilmente nós
teríamos observando apenas a imagem a
nível do sol
agora imagine quantas informações são
possíveis de se extrair uma imagem aérea
de uma cidade de sua forma completa
mas antes disso nós temos que pensar
como a cidade se forma em algumas
cidades foram pensadas para serem opção
é o caso por exemplo de barcelona mas a
grande maioria dessas cidades se criaram
ao acaso como uma colcha de retalhos
vou citar um exemplo uma pequena vila de
mineradores de em busca de ouro começa a
crescer com a chegada de imigrantes de
diversas partes do mundo para
agricultoras suas terras
eles começam o pequenos comércios
construir uma igreja e uma escola uma
indústria mais voz e ferrovia e logo em
algumas centenas de anos temos uma
cidade não é acaso que esse é um resumo
da história do surgimento de lavras mas
o que lavras barcelona e todas as
cidades do mundo têm em comum elas são
um desafio para a gestão urbana
elas são complexas e mesmo os seus
maiores conhecedores não são capazes de
conhecê lo como um todo
há dois anos eu participei de uma
reunião com algumas gotas integrantes da
secretaria de meio ambiente não
estávamos tratando sobre alguns
problemas ambientais que lavras tem uma
das maiores queixas que a equipe fazia é
que eles não conseguiram fazer o
planejamento das suas acções
eles sempre estavam fazendo ações
paliativas corrigindo problemas que já
existiam porque eles não tinham base de
informações para fazer esse planejamento
ao longo dos anos e foi que pensamos
talvez a solução para esse problema
poderia vir do céu não com a ajuda de
deus mas sim do seu como vimos no caso
de paris isso as imagens aéreas são
poderosas ferramentas para gestão de
grandes áreas sendo que elas podem ser
obtidas por aeronaves por helicópteros
por meio de balões
os satélites e mais recentemente por
meio dos drones
quando trabalhamos com imagens aéreas
praga áreas urbanas é possível realizar
grandes estudos e obter grandes
informações vou citar algumas alguns
exemplos podemos acompanhar o
crescimento dessas cidades
porém podemos observar algumas
desigualdades sociais que normalmente
ocorrem dentro de uma cidade
podemos observar a distribuição da malha
das malhas viárias alguns conflitos
ambientais que ocorrem ajudar no
controle e mapeamento de algumas
epidemias identificar alguns crimes
mapear algumas áreas de alguma
áreas de risco e também avaliar como
está acontecendo a ocupação dos lotes
dessa cidade
quando juntamos essas várias camadas de
informações atrelados com a localização
de onde essa informação está vindo
nós criamos uma ferramenta chamada banco
de dados geográficos e à democratização
do drone vem tornando essa ferramenta
cada vez mais acessível tanto em
pequenas quanto a médias cidades
hoje com baixo investimento é possível
que qualquer prefeitura seja capaz de
mapear alimentar criar e que atualizar
um banco de dados geográficos qualquer
um de nós aqui é capaz de uma pedra uma
cidade só é preciso ter um drone pra
isso eu gostaria de trazer para vocês um
pouco da experiência que o meu grupo de
trabalho está tendo ao longo do último
ano um trabalho onde nós estamos
mapeando toda a área urbana de lavras e
construir um banco de dados com as
informações ambientais lavras
como a maioria das cidades é apresenta
alguns problemas no seu processo de
crescimento principalmente relacionados
à a malha viária problemas de
deslocamento com o problema de
loteamento planejados ocupação indevida
de algumas áreas
lavras numa grande cidade é uma cidade
de no máximo um porte médio com
aproximadamente 100 mil habitantes
ela se localiza no sul de minas gerais
um estado do sudeste do brasil e esse
trabalho é uma parceria que nós estamos
desenvolvendo junto com a universidade
federal de lavras e à secretaria
municipal de meio ambiente para mapear
toda a área urbana do município
foi necessário dividindo divididas em
pequenos quadradinhos esses quadrinhos
que vocês vêem na tela totalizando 366
quadrantes de aproximadamente 14
hectares cada um deles
quando falamos em 14 hectares o
equivalente a 3
e que 3,5 quilômetros em ambas as
direções
é uma área considerável que o vôo do
drone mapeei aproximadamente 25 minutos
gerando uma imagem de altíssima
resolução a um baixo custo e com o
tamanho de pixel que a menor unidade que
tem essa imagem de aproximadamente dois
centímetros o que nos permite observar
praticamente todos os objetos de
interesse nesse tipo de levantamento
outro problema identificado em lavras
era a falta de uma base cadastral
não adianta a gente ter uma imagem e não
saber o que essa imagem tem quando nós
fomos por exemplo que queremos conhecer
os limites dos lotes de lavras
a única alternativa seria o que chegaram
a prefeitura solicitará as plantas que
foram entregues no momento da do
planejamento e e aprovação de um
loteamento pra ver os limites seja dos
lotes onde tem uma praça
só que quando nós vamos fazer isso nós
temos essa realidade
nós estamos prontos de 60 anos e mais
só o acesso a esse documento já é
complicado imagina conseguir extrair
alguma informação deles e mais usá lo de
maneira rápida
isso é inviável o primeiro passo então
foi o que saímos da informação na era do
papel para a era digital
então nos sobrepormos a imagem obtida do
drone com altíssima resolução
como a base vetorizada da vida das
plantas de papel
então a partir daqui nós temos o que é
necessário para construir um banco de
dados geográficos
nós temos a menor unidade do banco de
dados que é o que cada lote urbano
nós temos as ruas então nós conseguimos
localizar o indivíduo áreas
individualizadas lotes
como eu disse o nosso foco está na área
ambiental
mas nada impede que a si mesma
metodologia sempre seja aplicada às
outras necessidades
nós podemos aplicar a qualquer
necessidade pois a imagem que nós temos
serve tanto para identificar uma árvore
como sempre identificar se existe um
número adequado de escolas e hospitais
dentro de um raio acessível à grande
parte da população o uso ou o produto
depende da necessidade e no nosso caso
nós estamos atendendo à necessidade
ambiental
nós vamos trabalhar no nosso banco de
dados com as localizações de todas as
árvores urbanas das áreas verdes que
existem dentro do município das praças
nascentes córregos e rios
além de fazer uma avaliação de qual o
estado dos terrenos vagos
então o que é feito para cada árvore que
nós vamos observar dentro dá por meio da
imagem ela vai ser localizada
aquela árvore apenas a localização dela
já é alguma informação mas infelizmente
o drone ainda não é capaz de avaliar
todas as informações que a prefeitura
necessita
então a localização da época ele é
apenas o primeiro passo para a
construção do banco de dados
complementarmente a isso um levantamento
em campo vai identificar qual é a
espécie daquela época
se essa é a obra está em conflito com a
rede elétrica
qual o risco de queda dessa água e se
ela está no local adequado mas apenas
conhecer o que existe não é o suficiente
pra nós
nós também queremos aumentar o número de
obras que existem no nosso município
só que essa esse número de água ele
precisa ser também feito de uma forma
correta e para isso nós lembramos também
nessa parceria
o manual de arborização para o município
nele consta todas as recomendações
técnicas para você plantar uma árvore e
no seu local adequado
então nós vamos falar qual o tamanho da
calçada quais espécies de aves
utilizadas como deve ser a abertura
dessas cobras fazendo o que o toda
árvore que seja plantada seja possível
mantê la no futuro
além disso o nosso mapeamento das
nascentes e córregos dos rios vai nos
permitir conhecer as áreas de
preservação permanente o que são as
áreas de preservação permanente são
áreas protegidas pelas leis ambientais
brasileiras
somente para a manutenção do
funcionamento dos recursos hídricos
alguns anos nós enfrentamos uma grande
crise hídrica no brasil
alguns de vocês talvez tiveram o
abastecimento das suas casas
comprometidos tiveram que andar com seus
carros subiu por alguns meses e muitas
vezes nós não damos a mesma importância
para nascente que existe ao lado da sua
casa
quanto à nascente está numa área rural e
abastece a sociedade mas se compra se
vocês lembrarem toda a água corre para
um rio maior e essa mesma água que nasce
na nascente vai alimentar um rio mais à
frente que pode abastecer a sociedade
com a dívida da individualização dos
lotes nós vamos otimizar muito trabalho
da prefeitura hoje em lavras
como em grande ou várias outras cidades
nós sofremos como um processo que chama
especulação imobiliária
hoje ter um lote é uma forma do que você
ganhar dinheiro
você compra um lote com um valor x
espera valorizar alguns por um valor 2 x
1 eo vídeo
isso faz com que grande parte dos
empreendimentos que existem no município
sejam assim cheios de lotes vagos
quais são as quais são as
responsabilidades que o dono desse lote
tem segundo algumas leis ambientais
municipais
ele deve manter esse lote cercado limpo
e com as calçadas feitas agora imaginem
lavras tem aproximadamente 3 mil
hectares de área urbana
quantas pessoas seriam necessários para
fiscalizar toda essa área seria bastante
né
agora imagine com a imagem de drone de
alta resolução
nós precisaríamos de uma pequena equipe
sentado em frente de um computador onde
ele analisaria as conformidades ou não
de cada um de cada lote
isso seria uma utilização do recurso
público e uma melhoria do cumprimento
das leis municipais
é lógico que nenhum banco de dados ele é
fixo ele precisa ser atualizado de
tempos em tempos mas a partir do momento
que você já tem um banco de dados bem
estruturado
a ação dele é corriqueira você apenas
precisa fazer uma imagem novamente que é
uma coisa rápida barata e atualizar as
informações que mudaram ao longo dos
anos
o nosso interesse é produzir dados que
melhorem a gestão do ambiente urbano
nós queremos fazer da cidade de lavras
uma cidade melhor
uma cidade mais arborizada que seja
capaz de crescer e crescer com qualidade
e nós queremos que essas melhorias na
tomada de decisão por parte do zedu dos
gestores municipais com o uso dessas
informações sirva de inspiração para
outras cidades e que elas também possam
trânsito transformar em locais lugares
melhores para sua população
muito obrigado a todos
[Aplausos]